الجمله الثقافيه
غير الهجوم الانحويه وغير الجمله البلاغيه
او الادبيه الجمله الثقافيه هذه تكون
نادره في الخطاب اي خطاب لكن اذا عثرت
عليها
فيتشكل الكاشف النسقي الذي ممكن
يكون كانه عنوان على على المعنى ان سقر
لتغلغل وتشابك وتشتت فكذا تجمع الشتات
بكلمه في كلمه للملك ادريس السنوسي ملك
ليبيا
لما سال عن جماعه الاخوان المسلمين قال
كيف اتعاملوا مع جماعه جسدهم في ليبيا
وراسهم في القاهره
شوف المعنى شوف الجمله الثقافيه هذا بمعنى
موجود عند القوميين وعند الاسلام
مهما كان في ارضه فليكن في اي ارض كانت
لكن راسه في بيت المرشد او راسه في بيت او
قصر الزعيم الاوحد
بالتالي هنا في انفصام
بين الارض نفسها التي تحمل هذا الجسد لكن
عقله
وهوائه
وابتغياته القصوى طرف اخر ليس من هذه
الارض فبالتالي كانه الغاء للارض نفسه
نفسه
وهنا هذا الانشطار الذي يفسر لنا سبب
انهيار معاني وشعارات الاخوان المسلمين
والقومين انهم هذا المريد الذي عندهم ذكر
قبل قليل الجيش المعنويه الذي كان يتصرف
عن حسن نيه ان هذا العمل العظيم
ذلك لكن الجمله الثقافيه
تحول الجيش المعنوي
الى شيء
يقوله الدرجه ان يرحل بنفسها اعطيك مثالين
سريع جدا جدا واحد لي انا وواحد للزميلي
انا لما توفي عبد الناصر الله يرحمه كتبت
قصيده وفيها بيتان صاء انا صادق فيهما
لانه توفي بالغلط
ليت قلبي قلب قلب قبل قلب قلبك ليس قلبي
قبل قلبك ليتني مت قبلك اقولها وانا صادق
فعلا بسبب الحماس العروبي الناصري زميلي
جميل للاسلام للاخواننا المسلمين
كان سيد قطب مسجون وكان في اخبار انه ممكن
يعدى لكن لم يعدم بعد لم ياتي لسه لسه في
الاخبار
كان يكفي ثوبه بالمكوه احنا طلاب وبيت
طلاب اخذ الماك علي يده
وصار يحرق يده انا قمت بسرعه
ماذا قال لي قال سيد قلب يعذب في سيد قطب
يعذب في الزنزانه وانا لابد اعيش
المعنوي الى هذا الجسد الذي هنا وراسه
في مكان اخر هل الجمله الثقافيه لادريس
السنوسي وهو مجرد واحد ملك يهمه بلده
وفيقولها كواقع ان كيف اتعامل
معذوبهم في القاهره الان
احنا في زمن بقايا الاخوان المسلمين كل
واحد من الاخوان المسلمين
جسده في بلده وراسه في بيت المرشد في مكان
مع اسطنبول بالقاهره باللي يصير
وليس في مكانه هذا هذا هو الذي جعلهم
مناقضون
لطبيعه الاشياء